the first speaker of the day
um mr simone simon is owner of
nova foui a strawberry and raspberry
plant nursery located in quebec
that specializes in plug and tray plants
he regularly visits producers and
researchers abroad
to adopt the latest techniques and
transfer them to industry
simone is very much interested and very
much involved at all levels of the
production chain
from breeding to marketing of fruits and
he is a member of several committees and
working groups
he is currently president of the north
american strawberry growers association
who's hosting this webinar series and
sits on the coordinating board of the
quebec
strawberry grower association in order
to participate in the development of the
sector
and to make sure that the technological
developments
in the company match the market's needs
simon
yeah thank you very much caddy i'm very
impressed with your good uh french
pronunciation
i'll try to do the same in english then
i'm very pleased to be part of this day
neutral strawberry production webinar
these kinds of interactive web events
sounds really new to us but
will become a standard definitely in the
years to come
it will never replace any personal
meetings or the friendly relations that
we share during congresses and
conferences but
it really has the advantage of putting
together people that live far away
from each other on the same network to
discuss a particular subject
so the topic i will approach today
is growing systems used for day neutral
strawberry production
i will first shortly explain how danger
trolls are developing in north america
among different climates and among other
growing systems
and then i will discuss the different
production scheme used in the northeast
of our continent to make day neutral
production
complementary and profitable with bare
roots or plug plants
so let's get started
as you know north america is a very vast
continent with a lot of climatic zones
and fortunately for us strawberries are
known among the most adaptable
cultivated crop that will fit well
in the most various condition so
acreages of strawberries
are grown all over the continent the
data you see on this slide or from
different sources and different years of
reference
so my numbers might not be all up to
date but i just want to give you a
general portrait
so you can see here some of the most
important production site in north
america
illustrated here with red circles which
are proportional to the acreage
eastern canada is is a big player over
10 000 acres
it is about the same in the north and
mid east of the united states
and then there is more than seven
thousand acres
i think now it's close to ten thousand
in the very south uh concentrated around
tampa in florida and california as close
to forty thousand acres
spread over the state so on the
following slide
instead of acreage you can see the
average yield
in each region therefore the scheme is
different
to explain this difference let me remind
you a few basics of physiology
it is really important that you all
understand this before we go further
remember that strawberry is a very
adaptable specie and it is a reason why
it is so fascinating to work with
you can crop the same plants in
different environment
and they will react in a completely
different manner
many people don't really know why summer
bearing strawberries are called
short day varieties so then let me
explain
it is because summer bearing varieties
build flower buds in the crowns
during the short days in fall and those
flowers will come out and bear fruit
only in the spring
so it is a combination of short days and
cool climate
that will induce flower body initiation
in short days cultivar
in the north this process takes place in
the fall
and the plants bear fruit in the spring
however
under lower latitudes like in florida
growing conditions are good all winter
long while the dayland stay short
so even the short day varieties that
normally crops only 3-4 weeks in the
north
they will give a continuous supply of
fruit over four or five months in the
south
so well this is for the short day types
on the other end
day neutral varieties will grow flower
bud even when the days are long and
temperatures are warm
so then even in northern latitudes they
will give a continuous production all
over the summer season
therefore stretching the picking season
from one month to five months
so let's get back again a few slides and
have a second look at acreage
so then let me show you again the
average yield that is increasing as you
go south
mainly because as i explained over
longer picking season
and then fasten your seat belt total
yield
here california and florida take most of
the screen
and they grow an enormous proportion of
north american strawberries
this is because their season is longer
and their yields are higher
i will always remember a conference
given by tom julian from driscoll
at the nasga congress who told us that
the only way the north could
could survive california's competition
is by adopting new growing systems
that will stretch the season and
increase the yields
and he pointed out they neutral
varieties as the most
obvious option in regards to the
international trends at our latitude
one of the advantage we have in the
north is that many of the commercial day
neutral varieties
actually available do not support well
intense heat
restricting continuous summer production
to areas
where the summers are not too hot
meaning in northern latitudes
or at high altitudes
now i will get into the more technical
part of my speech
and i will use quebec strawberry grower
system
as a reference so all the dates and
yields that i will show
are for a humid continental climate at
latitude 48 degree north
in quebec they neutral strawberries
occupy around 20
of our strawberry fields
more than 40 years ago california and
florida growers
adopt a new growing system on raised bed
covered with plastic mulch
and drip irrigation more than 30 years
ago
north carolina growers followed
introducing new plant types and
varieties
20 years ago the northern growers also
started to do the same
with they neutral varieties and they
adapted the system
to their condition
all day neutrals grown in the northeast
are
are grown on plastic culture it does not
seem to be profitable to grow the
neutrals in the traditional
matted rose system the plastic culture
system will increase
yield give a better fruit size increased
quality
a better uniformity efficiency a season
extension
and a better reliability
on the east coast the growers all use
the same suppliers for plastic culture
material
and mechanics therefore the general
specifications are pretty much
standard let's go rapidly to the most
important
so we use a black plastic mulch from 0.9
to 1.25 mil this depends on the duration
of the crop mainly the longer the
thicker
uh the bed height is from 8 to 12 inches
this will depends on the type of soil
and the bed shaper we
use gener generally the higher is the
better
with better drainage more heat but in
practice the standard is more around 10
inches the bed width is from 20 to 30
inches
the distance between the beds is from 48
to 60 inches
just really depends on the bedding
equipment you will use
and ultimately depends on the distance
between the tractor wheel
distance between the plants is 12 inches
and distance between the row
is from 12 to 14 inches on the bed this
depends on the bed size
you need to remember that plant must be
keep at least at least six
inches from the bed shoulder so fruit
don't lay on the ground and don't get
dirty
and finally the density is between 15
000 and 22 000 plants per acre
this will depends on all the other
distances stated above
but mostly the distance the distances
between rows
normally about half of nitrogen and
potash with all the phosphorus and
micronutrients
are applied broadcast before shaping the
bed
the other half of nitrogen and potash is
applied to drip irrigation
but i think john will probably explain
this a lot more about that later on
sprinklers are used for plant
establishment and for frost protection
row covers are also widely used for
fresh protection
and for season extension
so now i want to give you a brief
overview
of the different growing system that we
use to stretch our picking season in
quebec
those next results and slides come from
a very innovative grower in quebec
called david lemire from femgonio who
has been very kind to share this
information with us today
this grower is located in the middle
range climate of the province and
is often considered by his peer as our
our
barometer for picking season and average
yield potential
then you represent the average between
the coolest
and the warmest growing zone
so okay well i'm sorry here's uh the
slides title or in french i just
couldn't change them but i'm sure you
will understand
on the top graphic uh for all the
following graphic you will have the
trends in prices on our local market
which you can see is greatly linked with
the vibe the availability on fruit
of fruits on the market so this is on
the left the price for a 10 pound box
and on the bottom graph you will see how
we are using different systems
to fill the harvest season horizontally
you have the picking dates from june to
october and vertically
you have the yield that is picked per
week of harvests from each hectare of
field
on this first slide you can see prices
on the top graph
and yields on the bottom graph in blue
for the matador system
and in red for the day neutral system
that we use
with bare root plants and then over the
last few years we've added a lot
a lot many new growing system
so in light blue uh more recently we had
a jewel plug plants
that give an earlier cropping pattern
starting at least two weeks before the
matted row
to pick even earlier our company nova
fruit
introduced a new hurley variety called
clary shown here with the yellow line
it will start to crop three weeks before
jewel in matadro
and will be almost done picking with
when prices get lower
and finally and this is our subject we
added they neutral varieties
using plug plants shown by the purple
line instead of bare root plants shown
by the red line
plugs of seascape give a very hurly crop
followed by a continuous picking
all through october nowadays
there are basically two ways of growing
danger trawls in the northeast
depending on the plant type the most
popular system is to plant during
springtime with bare root dormant plants
and the alternative system is to plant
late summer with plug plants
today in quebec the spring planted bare
roots are used on 80 percent of the
acreage
while plugs are used on 20 percent of
the fields
quebec growers are nearly putting in the
ground eight million plants of seascape
and a few other day neutrals
bare root dormant plants have been the
standard plight for many years in the
matador and plasticulture system
they are grown for a full season in the
nursery field
dug in the late fall and kept in the
cooler during winter
they are very adaptable and provide many
opportunities to use in different
growing system
as well as being relatively cheap
compared to other plant types
plugs are runner tips that have been
rooted in peat based media
they are also called misted tips in
other areas
they are rooted in the nurseries in july
and planted in the field late august in
quebec
plug plants cut cost at least double the
price of bare roots so
it is a more risky business but they
also give an earlier production
better fruit quality and they can to
some extent be planted mechanically
so let's come back to the bare root and
let me describe the spring planting
system
with bare roots that we use to grow the
neutrals
these fields are are treated as a as an
annual crop
as soon as possible in april the first
thing that growers do is shape their bed
lay plastic
and put the bare roots in the ground as
you can see on this picture
and this is what it looked like a few
days after planting
the flowers are removed during four to
six weeks
to help the plant build up a good leaf
canopy that will support the summer crop
if the plants are too weak at the
beginning of the harvest in july
they will lag behind all summer long we
always try to keep in mind marketing
consideration and
the fruits from those first flower would
be harvested at the end of june when the
prices are at their lowest range
so the decision for us is easy to make
in week and we cut the flowers
until mid-june and this is to support a
stronger crop that will last until fall
if a good plant balance is maintained
and the crop is kept free of pathogen
fruit production can last until the end
of october and even a little later in
november with the use of row covers
the growers are picking in average 25
000 pounds per acre on day neutrals
about 1.3 pound per plant making this
system among the most productive in the
north
however however
a lot of cost and risk are involved into
this business
making it very challenging all the
profitability is based on one single
season
so it can easily become an economical
disaster if something goes wrong
an infestation of spider mites tarnished
plant bugs
or even powdery meals you can greatly
affect the the crop quality and yields
some of the bare root they some of the
bare root day neutral fields
are overwintered to give an early spring
crop the following spring
if the yields were low during the first
year it can still give a good second
crop
however in our nurtured conditions a
planting that has given 25 000 pounds
per acre the first year
will have very big and ramified plants
and those plants will tend to give
small fruit of lesser quality the second
year
this system of holding seascape plants
for a second year
is well known by the buyers here who
state that we should not start our
picking season with such a low quality
fruit
it is partly as an answer to that to
that demand
that strawberry growers have started to
use plug plants
so over the last five years an
increasing proportion
of day neutral plantings in quebec have
been done with plug plants
now more than 20 percent of the neutral
plantings in our province are done with
plugs and
it is still increasing every year
plugs are planted late august then the
plants are grown late in the fall
under a row cover and they are in
perfect conditions to build up those
flower buds
that will give a very early quality
spring crop
with plugs the flowers don't need to be
cut like with dormant plant
because plugs are already well
established since the previous fall
so you can get a very early june crop of
about
15 000 pounds per acre
here you can see the difference in the
cropping pattern between bare root
and plugs as you can see the plug
harvest is very hurly
and gives us a very good premium price
for the first week of picking
on this site for 2008 plugs have been
more productive than bare root by only
10
but we often reach 20 to 25 percent
increase in yield with plug plants
however we need to consider that plugs
are two to three times
more expensive than bare roots and that
there is a real risk of winter damage on
the plug
that you we don't have to deal with with
the spring plantings that are treated as
an annual crop
so now that you know the general pattern
let me show you a few things about plugs
and
about plugs that we have discovered
recently
one of the advantages with late
plantings
is that you can manipulate those plant
in different ways depending on what you
are looking for
so here is the first scenario this is
what will happen
if we put the plugs in the ground in
september
so late planting and if we don't push
them too hard in the fall
the fl the following spring this is what
you will get
these late planted plug will give a very
hurly crop of high quality fruit
the spring yield however will be lower
it can be less than ten thousand pounds
per acre
but after a three four week gap the
plants will come back with a very heavy
production in august and september
which is almost as good as with bare
root plants
then the second scenario with the red
line
this is if we push the plant as much as
we can during the planting year so for
example we plant early in august
we put the row covers early we fertilize
and water a lot in the fall
this will tend to give a very strong
plant in the spring that will
crop a little later than the than the
late planting but that will give a very
heavy spring crop
it can range it can range from twelve
thousand pounds to sometime more than 15
000 pounds per acre with seascape in our
area
however it seems that we cannot cheat
the plant and that there is a maximum
yield potential for a certain variety
in a certain field here on this graph
both system
have given the same 24 the same total of
24 tons per hectare
in this trial what happens most of the
time
is that after the heavy spring crop in
early june
the plants are getting tired and the
late summer yields are always lower than
with the bare root plants
this reduction in arves gets even worse
in situation where the
the spring yield is higher and where the
climate is warmer
so at the end you more or less get the
same yield with the early planting than
with the late planting
but the picking are staggered
differently over the season
i would like to come back to the slides
i've shown earlier from a quebec grower
called
david lemire now that we know that we
can manipulate the plants
this very ingenious grower started
figuring out how
he could how we could fill the gap
between short days
and day neutrals in the middle of the
summer
so let me show you on on the screen
well this part here he has experimented
different techniques
to find out that if we leave just a few
flowers in the spring
for a very early crop and if we cut all
the flowers that comes out during the
last three weeks of may
we can this way bring the gap earlier in
june and come back
later on in july with a better
production than if we would have
than if we would leave all the flowers
on
so this is what it will give
this flower management treatment gives
this brown curve that fits right when we
right when we need more fruits and when
the prices are at their highest range
so as you can see we now can pick
strawberries on a regular base
all the way from june to october by
managing
the different growing systems and plant
types
as many of you as many of you already
know there are many development in
europe concerning substrate production
high tunnels and greenhouses
dinner trawls are grown in many
countries as uk
france belgium the netherlands and so on
the trend is to cover the crops with
high tunnels
and with greenhouses as they neutral
varieties benefit a lot from this
protection and from a longer picking
season
in some countries almost 100 of day
neutrals
are grown under protection
substrate production on hanging gutters
has also become very popular and most
european breeding program
on day neutrals are developing varieties
for that particular application
i will not get into details today
because this would make another
conference but i just want you to
realize that
much is to come with the neutral
varieties and that we are just at the
beginning of a major revolution
for northern growers
i often show this this sentence and
conference
this sentence i heard from peter vinson
in united kingdom
20 years ago we had 20 different
varieties in one growing system
now we have 20 ways of growing the same
variety
it really reflects well the sand or
grower
are growing or following with the
neutral varieties
so if you wish to have more details
i invite you to visit our website at
www.novafruit.com
well you can find all the different
graphs and the different growing systems
we are using here
our plug plant nursery which you can see
here is located southeast of montreal in
canada
our goal is to grow the best strawberry
plugs in the northeast
and supply this new emerging market
so i'd like to thank you very much for
your attention
thank you very much simone we do have a
couple of questions
kay would like to know when would the
june bearing plants be producing in your
climate
uh okay well there there is a difference
of about 10 days from
from the south of montreal to the east
of quebec city
but let's let's let's uh take david
lemire as an example
so we will normally start to pick the
earliest planting
by the latest days of may so for example
the clary used
as plug plants will be picked like the
25th of may
and then the jewel as plug plant will be
picked
from the 5th of may and then we get into
the
the bare root short day uh well i need
to talk about the seascape also that
would normally
be picked between the first and the
fifth of may if used
as a plug and then we get into the the
bare root plantings on plastic that will
start to pick around
the 10th of of june and then we get into
the matted row system between the 15th
and the 20th of june and then we get
into some of the programming crop this
is another system that i haven't talked
about but we get small
yields from program it crop by the first
days of july
and then from about mid july we get into
the day
the day neutrals uh both plugs that are
coming back for a second production
and bare roots that are coming up with
their first production
so well it's a bit confusing but there
there's a lot of system that we
use now to spread our growing season
thanks simone and laura mcdermott would
like to know
do the early seascape fruit compete well
with the traditional june bearers like
jewel
in terms of flavor and customer
acceptance
uh well this is a very good question
yes for seascape but if we are talking
about this the seascapes that are
held for a second year uh no the quality
is very low the fruit size is lower the
shelf life's lower
the taste is lower uh while with young
plantings as with plug plants
or also with with uh with bare roots but
that haven't produced a lot on the first
year
then we can get a very good quality
early in the spring what happens
normally with seascape is that
we get a lower quality during the
warmest period of the year
so in july when temperatures are very
warm the
the quality can decrease but early in
june and later on in august
uh with seascape here we can get a very
good quality fruit
that can compete with with jewel
mickey from poland would like to know
about the winter hardiness with day
neutrals
oh well this is another very good
question uh one of the reason
why we have such a bad quality and such
bad results with overwintered
seascape or albion or any other of the
day neutral that we grow here
is because of winter damage so the
plants normally in the spring are
kind of weak they push out a lot of
flour they do not have a lot of good
leaf coverage or good leaf canopy to
support those fruit
so this is how we get a low quality uh
one thing you need to remember with
winter hardiness is that the older the
plant
the weaker it will be to to go through
winter so
with old plantings we get those winter
damage
while when we work with plug plants that
are planted in august with very young
tissue and very young plants that has
been grown
in the same summer then winter
resistance becomes very good
so we almost never see winter damage
on seascape plugs uh while we
we most of the time see winter damage on
on the bare root plantings that that are
overwintered for a second here
but we you we need to use row covers on
the plugs
and in the areas where the the snow
coverage is not very good we also use
fences in the in the field so let's say
that
each 10 or 15 rows will put the fence
all across the field just to accumulate
more snow during the winter time
okay are there any other questions for
simone
and you'll have a chance to ask more at
the end
okay kevin comes with a nice question
also where is there
not more albion i know that in ontario
albion has taken a lot of place
uh if we talk about the bare root plants
we have a very good quality crop with
albion but the problem is that we pick
it very late
so we'll start to pick it let's say by
mid august we'll start to have good
yield out of it
and the season is so short afterward
that we just cannot pick the yield out
of it so
albion is not using our climate uh
with with bare root plants with plug
plants the scheme is a bit different
because then the establishment of the
plant is done in the fall
and we start to pick early in the spring
so the the growth that albion need to
start production
it's considered as a as a weak day
neutral so it needs a lot a lot more
time than seascape to get established
and to start a good production
in in the spring with plug plants we
start to pick with albion but then if
the climate stays cool
seascape still gives better yield and
albion uh
as plug plant also so well over the last
four years i would say that
in the warmest region of quebec
two years out of four seascape still has
been better than albion as plug plant
and in the coolest place of quebec in
the coolest areas
uh let's say that one year out of four
albion has been better than seascape so
it is
not adopted yet as a as a variety the
fruit quality is wonderful
but we just cannot pick the yield out of
it with both types of plants
ian mcgregor would like to know what
thickness of row cover you're using
uh well another good question we uh we
have put we have thrown away all the
the row covers under 30 grams so the 19
gram per square meter row covers are not
used we use row covers between 30 and 40
grams
and what growers are considering now is
the durability of those row covers
versus the price and we realize that
investing in
heavier row covers like the 42 grams or
even the 60 gram or
double layer of 40 grams
gives us a longer durability so
well 30 to 40 30 to 40 grams per per
square meter would be the average in the
row covers used
okay simone will be back with us again
uh
at the end to answer more questions
we'll take this one more from
rajmund uh oh it's a comment he has
he agrees with simone about albion that
the fruits are too late and the yield is
low
and simone thank you very much and
please stay with us
and now i want to introduce to you our
second speaker
mr john zanstra john completed his
bachelor of science degree in
agriculture and master of science at the
university of guelph
and has been with the university of
guelph ridgetown campus since 1994.
he's responsible for conducting uh
cropping systems research on fruit and
vegetable crops in southwestern ontario
john is presently the coordinator of the
agriculture and horticulture diploma
programs at
ridgetown campus and also teaches
courses in fruit and vegetable crop
management
he manages the cedar springs fruit
research station
which is located on the north shore of
lake erie 15 kilometers east of the town
of blenheim
the main focus in the fruit research
program for the past few years
is the development of cropping systems
for day neutral strawberries including
high tunnel production
john hello
am i here you are here i am here i'm a
radio celebrity this is cool
um just to reflect what uh what simon
has said it's an interesting way to
to bring this information across so
we're happy to be here
um maybe just update again our add to
what you had
included the the site that we're working
on is kind of midway between
um london and windsor ontario so we're
about an hour and a half
to the east of of detroit so so north
shore lake erie
a warmer production area we have a fair
bit of trouble with production during
the hotter part of the summer and i'll
allude to that a little bit
so what i want to do is just score a
little bit of background why we're
interested in fertigation especially
neutral system um talk a little bit
about your irrigation because
you have to have a good handle on your
irrigation system if you're going to be
adding fertilizer through it
a few comments on fertilizer selection
um micronutrients and then
considerations and rates and some of the
techniques that we use to
put foundation in i also want to go over
a little bit of our
a little bit of our current research
that we're doing
and um and then just finish off some
micro nutrients and i
see that i've got a comment about
speaking loud is everybody able to hear
me all right
are we good for you there kathy john no
you need to be
louder how do i okay i've got this thing
cranked up but anyhow
we will try to talk a little bit louder
all right so why fertigate well we've
got it for
we've got a day neutral system we've got
uh raised beds and plastic and a drip
tape so why not put fertigation in there
it's a logical
um a logical extension of a typical day
neutral production system and
relative to or compared to say putting
everything on as dry fertilizer in the
spring
some of the published benefits of
fertigation and many of these will apply
to a
strawberry system you can feed the crop
as it needs it
there's a little bit being done at this
point in terms of targeting
different race fertility based on plant
development but i understand there's
some work in europe where they're
they're actually targeting the fertility
based on say the flower
development of the crop but it's
something we can move ahead with but
but it gives you a lot of flexibility in
terms of feeding the crop
you're putting the nutrition right where
the plant needs it in the root zone it's
it's available it's efficient
we see we see information
um suggesting savings of upwards of uh
say 20 30 percent in terms of fertilizer
because you're
you're getting it to the plant when it
needs it and in a form that's quite
available so here you've got some
savings there
so you've got product savings um
possible labor machinery fuel savings
because you're not having to go through
the field and do it mechanically
and lastly um your leaching potential
isn't there
um you manage where it goes through
irrigation water
um it's it's not going to be put on
early in the season and then you're at
the
at the uh you're you're working with the
weather to try and keep it where it is
so
so well you're able to work with that a
little bit better and that's some of the
focus that we've been working on as well
looking at
application efficiencies so we want to
talk a little bit about irrigation
you can't talk about fertigation without
knowing your irrigation system well
and and making it as efficient as
possible it's important to irrigate well
it's important to make sure that the
irrigation
is put on uniformly and i'm taking a
quote out of one of the references that
i used
a booklet titled fertigation and the
comment there is distribution of
fertigation can't be better than
than the distribution of water so you're
carrying one with the other
you've got to make sure you're putting
it in the root zone you want to give the
plants adequate water but you certainly
want to make sure that you're getting it
into the zone where the strawberry is
going to take it off so if you're
if you're flushing it all through you're
uh you're not doing a very good job of
it so
having things consistent in terms of
your irrigation approach is good so
things you want to consider when you're
irrigating for one um
weather conditions evapotranspiration
how much is
is being used by the plant how much is
being released by the soil how much
irrigation water needs to go back on you
need to consider the maturity of the
crop
as it gets bigger as it starts to hang a
crop as the plant increases in size it's
going to affect the amount of
water that needs to be put back um if
you've
not fertigated or irrigated strawberries
extensively
and you've worked with other types of
crops before it's not a
straight crossover so you've got to
consider the plant the size of the plant
again
the leaf area that's involved so a lot
of considerations
need to be to be uh put into place when
you're when you're developing uh
an effective irrigation system you also
need to be familiar with your soil how
much water is available to the plant
um you've got to know the rooting depth
of your plant
uh you you need to consider how able
that plant is to extract the water
and so for strawberries some suggestions
in the literature uh
indicate that strawberry will root up to
about 60 centimeters i think that's a
bit extreme especially in the
sites that we're on we're not getting it
that deep but anyhow get some idea of
of the effective area that the plan is
rooting into
a shovel would would be an easy way to
to confirm that
but again just just make sure that when
you're putting the water on which is
carrying the fertilizer that you're not
moving it
past the zone or you're not putting on
enough and not getting into the zone of
the roots of the plant some of the
parameters i talked about earlier
on the evapotranspiration the rooting
depth the water holding capacity of the
plant you can plug these into models
and and calculate how much water needs
to be added and when it needs to be done
these models are quite effective and
i've used a number of them in the past
and you can get quite accurate in terms
of
replacing the water that's being used
it's kind of running a spreadsheet
and topping up at the end of the day or
every couple days
so that's one approach you can also use
monitoring equipment i've listed a few
things here tensiometers tdrs things
that
are getting more affordable and and
growers might be able to use and are
somewhat
uh are fairly reproducible in terms of
the numbers that they give you
but again um even running irrigation
going out and digging and finding out
where it is
just to make sure that you're putting it
in in the zone where it needs to be so
so with these monitoring
techniques or this monitoring equipment
you can easily
see when that band of water comes
through they respond fairly quickly to
to irrigation water being added and that
way
keep keep track of of where the water is
going and
effectively where your irrigation is i
think people don't really realize a lot
of the time
how far water will move and this is a
table that i've picked out of again one
of the
booklets that i used as a reference and
what it does is relates
soil texture and moisture content of the
soil
i'm to the depth that the water will go
if you're say putting an inch of water
on on a particular soil so
i'm kind of flipping here between
imperial and metric my apologies but i
i um i didn't have time to convert this
but for example if you've got say a
sandy loam soil
and it's at a 50 water holding capacity
if you put an inch of water on that that
that water will will soak down about 16
inches into the soil so it's moving a
fair distance
and if you're dealing with a strawberry
crop you might be moving somewhat
out of where that plant is actually able
to pick up that
that fertility so you need to be aware
of that and
and again keep that in mind whenever
you're you're moving and
putting putting water on the plant
okay fertigation or fertilizer selection
there's a uh
there's a wide range of products that
you can use and i guess
the simplest thing is just to go get
some fertilizer that you would put on
the field it's a little more complicated
than getting a mixture but it certainly
is is
cheaper um just a few cautions
there if you're if you're using say
granular fertilizer you you always need
to do a test you always need to do a
combination of what you're putting on do
a jar test use the actual irrigation
water
um in particular if you're using say um
phosphate fertilizers and you've got
other other formulations with calcium in
it or if your water is extremely hard
and you're putting in say phosphate or
salty compounds you
you can get precipitates so put it in
the jar use the actual irrigation water
mix it up let it sit there for a day and
if there's any type of
of precipitator gunk in the water you
won't want to go over the field with
that you don't want to plug up your
emitters
can be problematic if you're using
prepared formulations intended for
fertigation or liquid fertilizers you're
usually
fairly fairly safe and it's not an issue
but
there is always that that temptation or
that opportunity to to
excuse me use commercial fertilizers or
granular so so that's there you also
have to keep in mind the
solubility of these fertilizers and
they're usually quite soluble but there
are
there are tables and charts out there
that that give you information on the
relative solubilities
ones again to keep in mind say if you're
using ammonium nitrate type fertilizers
they
vary in their solubility depending on
the temperatures um
uh ammonium sulfate ammonium nitrate are
a couple examples where that will change
so
so uh be familiar with what you're using
make sure it is quite soluble it'll go
into solution
but the uh the other approach then is
just to get um
just to get regular pre-made fertilizers
uh just to
give a bit of information or just to uh
review some of the information or some
of the macronutrients and the way they
move in
in solution and the way they're taken up
by the plant uh forms of nitrogen
are um are different in terms of plant
response and and um
a little bit of information on that is
helpful so plants normally take up
nitrogen as nitrate small amounts are
taken up as ammonium directly by the
plant
nitrate is is the uh the concern in
terms of leaching out of the soil volume
it uh
it's a negatively char it's a negatively
charged ion it's not held by the soil it
moves readily
in the soil solution it'll it'll leach
quite easily
ammonium on the other hand is positively
charged it doesn't move very well it's
um
it's held quite well by the soil doesn't
move far in the soil profile but it's
readily converted to
nitrates by soil organisms and then the
plant will take it up so so if you do
put a lot of
night or ammonium on it does get
converted eventually depending on the
soil and
soil temperatures and such but but it is
giving you a bit of a
a buffer there because it does it does
stay
in the soil doesn't move around fairly
quickly now feeding with
high levels of either form in a
fertigation
system can affect the the uptake of
other nutrients it's generally
recommended that you have a balance of
the two
in your fertigation program so if you're
if you're leaning towards heavy levels
of nitrate or heavy levels of ammonium
they can
upset other nutrients in terms of their
uptake
they can they can interfere with other
metabolic processes in the plant so
generally they recommend that you you
you use a fairly good mixture of the two
um some some factual figures that i've
come
across are say no more than 50 ammonium
uh no more than 60 nitrate in the
mixture we do find
examples in the literature where they're
looking specifically at strawberries and
looking at different ratios of the two
and
uh there are suggestions that
strawberries prefer nitrate over
ammonium and i've
even heard suggestions that one over the
other will promote vegetative growth
more than reproductive growth and you
may want to use that early in the season
to
to enhance plant growth but but
typically a mixture of the two
is good not um not moving too far in one
direction or the other
um a few comments on phosphorus soil
phosphorus as a whole
is not terribly available it's slowly
mineralized and
released to the plant it tends to bind
fairly tightly
availability is best at say between six
and seven
soil ph uh generally pre-planning
pre-plant incorporation is is more
economical when you're dealing
with a a particular strawberry crop
um some of the considerations there when
you're transplanting you want it to be
there so unless you've got your beds
down
uh sorry your irrigation in place and
you've started to put some phosphate
down
it's likely a good idea to have enough
in the soil when the plants go in
either as a plug or as a bare root plant
just to stimulate root development
get the roots going if you put some in
as a transplant solution be a good idea
but
but to uh to try and rely on a
fertigation system to put it all there
might not be the most effective way to
do it
uh with long season crop like strawberry
some suggest it might be useful to add a
bit through the fertigation but in
general it's
it's put down all pre-plant and then
it's
made of it's available to the plant
throughout the season plants don't
really require an awful lot of it
relative to
to nitrogen or or pot ash so
pre-planet or corporation of most of it
is usually
a good way to go potash as well most of
our soils have adequate pot ash it's
really only a small amount that's
available to the plant
and there's this equilibrium in the soil
between fixed potash and available pot
ash
it too a fair portion of it is often
pre-plant
incorporated it doesn't move far in the
soil it's often
well available to the plant but we often
like to to add a little bit through the
fertigation there
there's a fruit quality issues
associated with with extra potash and
it's again something that that we tend
to put a little bit in the in the
fertigation solution just to make sure
that
that uh enough is there enough is
available to the plant and in some cases
it's it's
recognized that even though the soil has
a lot there um that the amount that is
available to a planet
at any given time just isn't enough to
to provide adequate
growth and development so we'll add a
little bit to uh
to the fertigation solution as well
so when you're starting to fertigate
obviously the first thing you want to do
is test your soil
if there is adequate amounts there you
may not want to add any more through the
fertigation solution
um you want to make sure you know what
uh what is there so you're not spending
extra money putting putting material on
that you don't need you want to make
sure your soil ph
is in a range that that provides optimum
uptake of the nutrients and
optimum growth for the for the
strawberry depending on where
where you look and and where you're
located it can vary but generally
between six and a half and say seven
two seven three is the ph range that we
talk about
don't see a lot of reference in the
literature about testing irrigation
water but i don't think it's a bad idea
to do that either again just to make
sure that that you don't have any
high levels of particular nutrients in
your water to make sure that you're not
having to deal with really hard water or
water where the ph is off and it's going
to mess up your
your nutrient availability so know what
you're getting into and and
know know what your soil is like know
what your water quality is like just to
to be able to uh not have to worry about
those issues and
make sure that you're you're in good
shape there some of the things to
consider when you're
you're trying to determine the rates of
fertigation
um so i talked about how much is
supplied by the soil and the water
again in terms of the soil what your
previous crops are in terms of nitrogen
is there any residue there that's going
to be
providing extra nitrogen or residual
nitrogen in the soil um
keep in mind strawberries as well that
if you're dealing with a crop that
overwinters usually early spring growth
in a strawberry a lot of the
the nutrition a lot of the nutrition
comes from the plant itself
the crown of the plant at least for the
first few weeks of growth so you may not
have to feed it quite as heavy at that
point
um when the plant requires the nutrient
well again that's still
uh not terribly clear with strawberries
we're not um
we're not really advanced in that area
so that's hopefully something that will
come along
down the line so we can more more
effectively
feed the plant at particular areas when
it's looking for nutrient
so what rates do i use um p and k
again just general rates they don't have
a real big growth response in terms of
strawberry development nitrogen is one
we concern ourselves with most
depending on where you are i really
can't give any specific
recommendations obviously but um you
need to consider
again what your soil is like where where
you're growing what your your
seasonal length is if you survey the
literature
particularly in particularly in north
america
we see rates anywhere from no response
to additional nitrogen upwards of
three quarters of a kilo of nitrogen per
hectare per day
so again soil type will have a big
effect on that
in general it's felt that growers use
more than they really need
it might be seen as a as an insurance
policy but
um a lot of the time you really don't
need to put on as
much as you as you are um if you're
getting more than you need either you
you run the risk of losing it through
through leaching in the soil but also
a big lush plant isn't a good thing it's
well documented that
say botrytis and thoraconos incidence is
higher if you've got high nitrogen rates
fruit quality is poor storage is poor so
there are a lot of
a lot of drawbacks to having too much
nitrogen in your
in your in your fertigation as well i
was at a
talk a few days ago and this fellow was
talking about grape production and his
comment there was we're not
wood growers or fruit growers and i
guess you could sort of see the same
with strawberries you want a certain
size of plant but too much nitrogen in
particular is you're growing a lot of
extra leaf there
and it may not be necessary it may cause
you more trouble than you uh
then you actually are more problems than
benefits
in terms of application of fertigation
you want to be
um below a one percent solution in your
final mixture so you make up your stock
solution and there's a number of ways to
get it into the
into the fertigation or into the
irrigation lines
some sources say upwards of five percent
um others are more cautious since they
really don't want more than one percent
but the concern is damage to the roots
uh just shoving too much in there and
causing trouble
it varies with again with the
formulation the electrical conductivity
of the particular formulation and and
what type of plant you're dealing with
but it is a good line a good guideline
to go by so
our solutions never are more than one
percent um
depends on how quickly you put them on
as well but again it's a good guideline
to prevent any problems in the field
we try to get our applications of
fertigation on fairly quickly so what
we'll do is we prime the system make
sure everything's running well
get water through through all the drip
tape we try to get a fertigation on
within a half an hour generally they
suggest within a half to uh to an hour
you don't want to go longer than that
because you tend to dilute things and
again you want to keep it in that zone
of use by the plant
and then when it's all done we'll flush
the system again for another 10 or 15
minutes what we're concerned with there
is is
uniformity across the field if you've
got rolling topography you may get more
settling in the low areas
so you just want to make sure that that
the uniformity of application is is
maintained so
little flush afterwards it um seems to
work well and then you keep track of
your soil moisture and add more if you
need to but um the actual
fertigation application tends to be
fairly short
now you can also base what you put on in
terms of what the plant
uses and i've i found a few sources um
on the internet actually which which
suggests where or how much the
strawberry plant uses
over over a cropping system one of them
only
only one of them i should say really
indicated what the size of the crop was
and and
um of the three two were fairly fairly
close
in in terms of how much the crop
actually is but say for example on
nitrogen
now with this 30 ton crop there was kind
of a range but anywhere
between say 57 and and 78
kilos per hectare is taken up by the
fruit and the plant
to produce that 30 ton crop phosphorus
is
is fairly low potash is somewhere within
that range
the uh the sources that i found again
ranged anywhere from 63 to 92
magnesium 8 to 19 so so you can kind of
get an idea from that
what you need to be adding to your plant
if you're interested in just replacing
what is used by the plant you also need
to
again consider what is coming out of the
out of the soil itself what is being
mineralized and
and also what is being re-mobilized in
the plant but those are the sorts of
numbers that are actually being used to
to produce this crop and and
in particular the nitrogen levels are
fairly in fairly good agreement with
what we're finding in uh in the
fertigation work that we're doing
so again just an idea of what's being
taken up by the plant the last column is
just a breakdown of what percentage the
the fruit is using for
uh compared to what percentage of that
nutrient is is going into the plant and
maintaining the plant
so just to review some of the work that
we're doing we've been looking at
fertigation over a number of years in
ontario
simply because we don't have local
recommendations or
base recommendations on on other
locations in north america
we've got two production sites one in
the in the cedar springs station where
we are in one at the cinco research
station our
soil is fairly loamy um we've got a
ph of uh where we where we want at 6.6
organic matter of about three and a half
or three point three percent
compared to a coarse sandy soil on the
simcoe site so
what we did on these locations is um we
both grew
or we grew seascape at both sites our
populations were a little bit lower at
cedar springs
we had a range of nitrogen rates
anywhere from zero to 150 kilos per
hectare
over the season uh we would usually
start in mid-may and run to about
mid-october in
in terms of fertigation our timing was
or sorry
another treatment was timing where we
would start our fertigation program
later in the season we would put on 75
kilos but
we would also we would start it in later
july so we would load the back end of
the season more with with the nitrogen
and then lastly we had
a 75 kilo practice treatment but we
would also
put extra potash with it to see if there
was any effect
in respect to that nutrient in simcoe it
was a smaller trial because it's a ways
away we only use three rates of nitrogen
same variety that the seascape variety
in this case a commercial grower came in
and put the beds in so our our
populations were a little bit higher
and we also had a white plastic on that
site which uh we find is a little bit
better but we started with black and
cedar spring so we continued on so we
had three rates of nitrogen simcoe and
we also
had the the timing um
the timing treatment so 75 kilos per
hectare but beginning a little later in
the season so
so the applications were a little bit
larger at every given time
we put them on with the dosmatic which
is a commercial diluter
um can certainly be used in a field
situation uh we determined our rates
based on total land area not the area
under plastic
just to make the calculations easier and
have it to relate to the growers better
we
we worked on a 17 17-week period so for
example our 75 kilos per hectare is
about 4.4
kilos of nitrogen per week and and i
think that's about 0.6 kilos
per day so we started applications of
mid-may finished in mid-october
in um the nitrogen source that we use is
is
28 liquid which is a combination of urea
and ammonium nitrate
and in our pot ash treatments we added
um
a potassium nitrate and then topped it
off with 28
liquid just to give us our 75 kilos per
hectare nitrogen
in cedar springs um we really had
no significant difference amongst
treatments now what you're seeing here
is
is our fall crop so our planting system
our production system
that we follow is we plant in may we we
harvest say late
july early august through through the
fall
and then we'll keep that crop over the
winter and we'll do a spring flush and
so we'll start to harvest
again say mid may and go to about maybe
late june july
and that's that's what we mean by fall
and by spring so
fall crop year of planting um and again
on a per year basis no statistical
difference i've put the three years
together i've not done the stats on this
but you can see there's not a huge
response in terms of increasing nitrogen
rates
uh maybe a bit of a trend increase when
we get up to say 25 75 kilos per hectare
what i find interesting is we're seeing
a bit of a boost if we're putting on
that
fertility late so there seems to be a
bit of advantage at least in the first
year
uh the year of planting of of putting
more in later in the season versus
earlier in the season than the thought
is
just getting that crop developed and
feeding it later in the season to get it
going
if you uh if you look at the following
year the spring crop so this is the
the crop the year after it was planted
again
no real response in terms of nitrogen
rate as we go across
from zero to 25 to 75 and they're even
tending to decline as we get into the
higher nitrogen rates
uh no real benefit there of of putting a
late crop in
or sorry a late nitrogen application or
loading it up late in the season
and uh we we really don't see a huge
benefit
at this point either of the high potash
it's fairly similar to what our
our best treatment is in terms of just
the overall nitrogen rate so
we didn't see a huge benefit in in terms
of adding that extra potash on this site
now in in cedar springs we were um we've
got this high
organic our high organic matter three
and a half percent organic matter
in some of our early season soil tests
we were finding that we were getting
about 20 part per million
of nitrate available to the plant which
they tell me equates to about 70 80
pounds of actual nitrogen so
we had a fairly good rate of nitrogen
available to those plants early on in
the season which which may explain what
we're not getting any response to
to uh applied nitrogen in our
fertigation
if we look at simcoe in our fall crop
it's on a coarser soil it's a sandier
soil you can see on the top graph is
our marketable yield in response to
nitrogen and we can see there's a fairly
good response to
to increasing rates of nitrogen as we
would expect
and here again in in the fall in the
year of planting in our fall crop
we're seeing a bit of a boost by putting
on
the um the nitrogen having more put on
later in the season versus evenly across
the entire
production season if we uh look at the
win or the the spring crop in the same
planting again we're seeing this
rate increase as we're going from zero
upwards to
125 kilos per hectare the the benefit of
the
laid out applied nitrogen in terms of
marketable yield really isn't there
similar to what we saw in cedar springs
so so uh
seeing the same sort of trend there but
but obviously on this coarse soil
um we're seeing more of a response to
nitrogen than we are on the
on the uh the lumiere ground so so um
here too
we don't see a real response on the
loams when we get into
the sandier soils there seems to be more
of a response because likely the
just the lack of of or the lower organic
matter the
the higher rate of of um
of leaching if it's there so not
completely unexpected
okay moving on to micronutrients um
a lot of a lot of people try to to sell
sell you micronutrients um my philosophy
on that is unless you know you've got a
problem
if your soil is well maintained if your
ph is good if you've got good
good healthy production practices i
don't really
see a use in that um
my suggestion which i've heard from
others is is if you want to get a
baseline
of what micronutrients should be in your
crop we do have recommendations in
ontario
of what the the level of nutri nutrients
in the plant should be
based on tissue samples but if you want
to know what it's like on your
own site um go to an area on your farm
where you've got good production where
you're happy with with how the plants
performing and they look healthy
take some tissue samples send them to
the lab kind of get a baseline of of
what is in your plants at that
particular location and then if you run
into trouble
you can compare them to that you can see
where you're you're getting
getting into trouble and and may explain
some problems that you're seeing if
there are in fact micronutrient
deficiencies
there are suggestions in the literature
of high boron requirements uh we've not
seen that on our sites um we spend a lot
of time
on uh the only one that i'm really
familiar with is is um
is iron and becky hughes who works for
the university of guelph and our in a
northern location
regularly um adds foliar iron to her day
neutrals because of uh
because of a deficiency she's got there
on the clay but certainly not something
that we've seen
where we are where we are in
in our site um this is a a series of of
samples that i took um early on when we
started working with day neutrals
weren't really familiar with them
this is the the second year crop so this
is the year after planting this is a
seascape crop
at our cedar springs site we talk off
about 19.5 tons per hectare on on this
particular planting and we refer to
fertigating with a complete blend triple
20 and putting on about
0.6 kilo per hectare per day and we
would put them on once a week
and so um we were we were seeing some
symptoms under our tunnels this is the
outside
production where i was taking the
samples from but we were seeing some
some symptoms that we weren't really
sure uh were were
we weren't really sure what was going on
and so the concern was micronutrients so
we started
sampling and we tried to get in every
two weeks and and take fully expanded
leaves recently expanded leaves so
they're fairly young and
analyzing the petioles of them and uh in
the second column that's the recommended
rates in ontario you can see the dates
as we go across what our nutrient status
was and
the red the red numbers
indicate where we were falling below the
ontario
recommended rates and you can see
there's a few cases where
nitrogen was dipping a little bit but
certainly we weren't wildly low
in our rates um potash again a little a
few times
mid-season where we were getting below
the recommended rates but but
uh not moving out in any any great
degree so
so um it really wasn't anything to do
with nutrition and then we realized now
that was more heat stress on the plants
than anything but
um it was just a nice way to to kind of
see
where we're going what our nutrient
status was in particular the micros and
and uh just managing them without
putting any great effort on micro
we're seeing any big problems there and
no big differences
so just some general comments to
summarize the fertigation topic
if you're new to it uh start simple
become comfortable with your irrigation
system and your
your fertigation systems again
uniformity is is important in putting
the water down and then when the
fertility is carried along with it
hopefully that will will follow the same
trend
um soil testing and tissue testing are
good indications of what's available in
the soil
and what's getting into the plant and
it'll it'll set up some guidelines for
you and
in all cases make sure your record
keeping is good what products you were
using what rates you were putting on
if you were happy with the condition of
your plants if you think your yield
potential was there
you can always go back and look at those
and they give you a good indication of
what was going on
as you move on you can refine them um
one of the questions i've got is whether
or not
more frequent smaller doses of fertility
are applicable
um kind of thinking in terms of
vegetable transplant production where
where daily applications we find are
more efficient and easier to do than say
weekly applications
um applications based on on plant growth
is something i think that is up and
coming and and might be interesting but
we
don't think we really have the
information on that yet uh differences
in variety um
we wonder if albion just needs a little
bit more to push it along because it
tends to be a little slower maturing as
simon mentioned but
but also it tends to we think need a
little bit more
in terms of uh of growing the plant
and then just sap testing on the farm
there are a number of um
instruments where you can go into the
field yourself and then test for
different nutrients and
and whether that could be part of a
fertigation program just to
try and maintain the quality and the
nutrient status of the plant as you go
through the season
okay that kind of concludes what uh what
i wanted to talk about i just got a list
of some of the
books and uh yeah the books that i used
to put this together and
and there were a number of research
articles as well that that we looked at
so
so if you want to look at them further
so thank you for your time and uh
yeah okay
okay john thank you very much there are
some questions in the chat box
uh the first one is from rajmiki again
he's wondering if the application of
multi-microbial inocula as a bio
fertilizer
could be more effective in plants growth
promotion than humic acid application
oh i really have no experience with
any of that um
um yeah i've not at all worked in that
and i really didn't focus on that when i
was reviewing the literature so
sorry i i really don't know what to say
in that respect it's certainly an
interesting area looking at
biofertilizers but
it isn't something that i focused on in
in terms of this presentation
okay rod elmstrand would like to know uh
why white plastic or black we're in a
fairly warm production area so we prefer
white it um it doesn't give us a good
head start in the season but when we get
into the warmer part of the summers
we notice a difference on on in terms of
production and quality so white is
better black just gets too warm
it just isn't a good situation for us we
want to we want to be able to cool the
plants or grow them in a cooler
environment
i was just joking with a plastic
supplier a few days ago ideally it would
be nice
we would have something that was black
in the summer and then started to fade
and and turn white later in the year but
um the thought has been about uh
white washing and we've looked at these
skunk-type plastics as well
but the basic reason is is we're warm we
want a cooler environment for our plants
so so we use a white plastic
kay is wondering if there's any other
research with white plastic around the
country or the world so if any of our
other participants
have some comments on that please feel
free to weigh in
rajman has one more question about uh
once again if the phy or the phosphate
form of phosphorus can be considered as
a fertilizer
um again not
not familiar with that form of
fertilizer
not uh i assume again this is in the in
more of the biofertilizer
approach but sorry not not uh not
familiar with that
okay kay is wondering how your spring
yield results compare to simon's
comments about
the spring crop being poor simon are you
with us
and does the second year spring harvest
happen in may
when june bearing begins in mid-june
um maybe if i could start our in our
area our
day neutrals uh usually have a week or
two
uh benefit or earlier production than
our our day
or than our june bears they just seemed
to start off earlier
so for comparing side by side
day neutrals that were planted the
previous year their spring crop
the following year tends to be earlier
than a an established june bearing crop
just just the nature of the plant um
our spring crop the year after planting
also tends to be um
smaller the fruit size isn't quite as
big but we we do get a fair
bit of crop in that second year so we're
going with a spring planted bare root
plant that we would put in in may
uh we'll start to crop it again in july
late july
august september and as long as we can
go the second
year you tend to lose a bit on fruit
size but we do get a fairly decent crop
in that second year
once we get into the heat of the summer
at this point we usually abandon it
because it's
the crowns are getting big the plants
are starting to get tired
we've tried different things to carry
that crop further in that second year we
do have some growers in ontario that
that are able to do it successfully but
i'm not really sure what they're doing
but we're not able to win the location
that
we're at another question
is if it's better to apply
micronutrients especially boron as a
foliar spray or soil application
uh boron is easily applied as a foliar
um i think it's uh a little less
expensive putting it in the soil
um boron is is tricky because
you don't need an awful lot of it um and
and often toxic
toxicity symptoms may be somewhat
similar to
to deficiency symptoms um
i've not seen deficiency symptoms in our
plots
i've heard a lot of trouble with with
people getting a little carried away
with it but
either way it can be done but again i
think the
the more effective way is is to put it
on or sorry the more economical ways to
put it on
as a soil application if you know
there's a problem but but certainly it's
it's able to be put on
um through foliar sprays and it is
effective to do it that way
okay and then i believe
the last question was from
john branstrader he's wondering if
you've worked with calcium nitrate and
if you could give us some input on that
i've not worked with calcium nitrate it
is um one that that you hear people
using especially if they're
if they're interested in getting more
calcium to the plant
our soils are naturally very high in
calcium so i'm not at all concerned
about about calcium in the plant if you
uh
if your your irrigation is timely
and and consistent calcium uptake um
isn't usually an issue for us so um no i
have not worked with it in particular
uh we we've stuck with just the
the liquid 28 as ours our major nitrate
or nitrogen source
okay then does anyone have questions for
either
simone or john
while we're waiting i just want to
remind you that
the last in the mini series on day
neutral strawberries the last webinar
will be next friday march 4th
we'll have dr frank lowes from north
carolina state university talking about
diseases and their management and dr
david handley from university of maine
talking about insect and mite management
for day neutral strawberries
i want to thank simone and john for
their excellent presentations
and we'll take any questions that you
may have in the meantime
okay michael collins is wondering if
there you have any ideas for soluble
organic fertilizers to use in drip
uh again no you're you're uh
you're asking the wrong person i really
i really don't i'm not aware
of what's available in terms of organic
fertilizers um
yeah certainly an interesting market but
i just don't have any experience in that
in that area
any other questions
thank you very much thank you all for
participating this week
and we'll have our third webinar
in the series next week
have a good afternoon thank you have a
good day
thank you
you